la raison d'être de ce boulevard
périphérique et d'améliorer la
circulation dans la région parisienne et
en particulier aux limites de paris 25
avril 1973
pierre messmer alors premier ministre
inauguré le boulevard périphérique
parisien
un projet monumental dont les travaux
ont commencé à la fin des années 50
mais très vite le périphérique devient
un des axes les plus bruyants la
capitale maintenant le bruit du
générique alors là c'est intenable et le
jury ont l'objectif d'activité des
boules quiès les oreilles et vous avez
des personnes qui sont atteints de
dépression nerveuse
c'est ce qu'il faut regarder c'est
terrible les amis passent et le discours
est le même de la part des riverains
certains habitants excédés par le bruit
sont à bout comme cet homme en 1990 je
suis à bout de nerfs parce que vivent là
dedans et respirer ça hein je ne sais
pas champion organismes cas ce que ça
donne mais je suis à bout je suis sous
tranquillisants je ne peux plus dormir
le soir je sors mon chien à 2 3 heures
du matin c'est la grande déprime au sens
du mot et j'ai même des huit des idées
suicidaires je suis en longue maladie
afin de lutter contre ces nuisances
sonores des murs antibruit sont
installés partiellement le long du
périphérique à partir des années 80 bien
les riverains douter de leur efficacité
le mur ça servira absolument rien pour
nous le mur vingt rêver à la hauteur du
plafond
le rez de chaussée et s'est tout même
celui qui va habiter le premier étage
pour lui sam joueurs il y aura toujours
la nuisance malgré la mise en place de
ces murs antibruit les nuisances sonores
restent très importantes sur le
boulevard périphérique
plus de trente ans après son
inauguration rien n'a changé
du bruit du bruit et encore du bruit
pourquoi annoncer et l'enfer ici hein
c'est à dire eh ben il ya trop de
voitures est trop de bruit pour lutter
en partie contre le bruit et les
embouteillages
la maire de paris anne hidalgo avait
déjà abaissé la vitesse une première
fois en 2014 à 70 km heure une mesure
qui n'avait pas eu beaucoup d'effet en
journée l'abaissement avait permis de
limiter très légèrement le bruit 0.5
décibels en moyenne d'après brute paris
[Musique]